[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 en el estudio Daniela hablemos de la
economía de Qatar Hola Raúl Pues con dos
coma nueve millones de habitantes
Qatar es uno de los países per cápita
más ricos del mundo con parte junto con
Irán una de las reservas de gas natural
más grandes del planeta y es uno de los
proveedores por excelencia ahora que ha
bajado el suministro ruso mientras gran
parte del mundo Lidia con la recesión y
la inflación
Qatar y otros productores de petróleo
del Golfo Pérsico están cosechando los
beneficios de los altos precios de hecho
el fondo monetario internacional Espera
que su economía crezca alrededor de 3,4%
este año tiene además un superávit
fiscal y la familia gobernante tiene
participaciones en cosas que van desde
finanzas y tecnología hasta el club de
fútbol francés París Saint Germain y
vienes raíces en Londres el país también
ha sido objeto de un intenso escrutinio
mundial por sus políticas laborales
que solamente uno de cada 10 y el país
ha sido un imán para la mala prensa por
sus leyes laborales y el tratamiento que
les ha dado a los migrantes en su
mayoría del sur de Asia que le ayudaron
a prepararse para el mundial A pesar de
que este es considerado un mundial de
lujo pues hablando de esto sin importar
que sean inasequibles las el mundial
para la gran mayoría también hay Quienes
no necesitaron de muchos recursos para
viajar como este argentino que vamos a
escuchar
tanto
Estoy muy emocionado no solo porque
estoy aquí en Qatar donde comienza la
copa del mundo sino porque también
llegué aquí en
bicicletari formansegol sale de Italia
Hace cuatro meses con un amigo y
pedaleamos 5.500 kilómetros a través de
todos los Países Árabes como Irak
Turquía Kuwait Arabia Saudita y también
estuvimos en Europa
y le preguntó Daniela Cómo captar pasó a
ser sede de este mundial pues pasado más
de 200 mil millones de dólares en
infraestructura y otros proyectos de
desarrollo incluidos ocho estadios
hablamos con Pablo César Cortés
periodista especializado en deportivo Y
actualmente trabajando en ESPN quien nos
contó primero porque fue
Qatar El Elegido precisamente
catari Rusia llegan al mundial porque
había tenido pérdidas en Brasil y en
Sudáfrica entonces la forma de poder
buscar reivindicar sus arcas era llegar
a un país que les pusiera todo porque
ellos tuvieron que subvencionar de
alguna manera lo que pasó en Brasil y lo
que pasó en Sudáfrica Porque eran países
que no tenían el músculo económico para
poderlo hacer Brasil Brasil fue un tema
de corrupción también se hicieron
algunos estadios entonces Brasil el
estado brasileño no tuvo como tapar esos
huecos y al esfera tocó por debajo
cuerda dar
generar generar ese dinero Por eso es
que aparece el FIFA gay porque tiene que
ir acomodando todo para darle a Rusia y
acatar estados que invirtieron y que
hicieron sus
este mundial tiene siete estadios nuevos
además estadios climatizados entonces
tiene cosas que otros mundiales no han
tenido en cuanto a esa situación y todo
eso todo eso lo dio catar la FIFA
entregan algunos mundiales sobre todo
los mundiales juveniles Alguna algún
tema de dineros de apoyo para que se
puedan generar algunas infraestructuras
pero pues aquí la FIFA no pagó el metro
que va a unir los estadios en catarnia
ayudó con la estructura de las
carreteras ni mucho menos ni el
aeropuerto lo construyó en Brasil sobre
todo le tocó meterse la mano al drill
como decimos acá en Colombia para poder
subvencionar ese mundial bueno Y como el
mundial va a impactar la economía catari
pues no es un país que necesite mucho
dinero pero sin embargo la firmada de
investigación británica capital
economics Calcula que 1,5 millones de
turistas llegaron a doha si cada
visitante se quedara 10 días y gastar a
500 dólares por día el gasto de cada uno
ascendería a unos 5 mil dólares según
esta firma de investigación eso
representar un impulso de 7.500 millones
de dólares para su economía este año
el mundial También ha generado Daniela
distorsiones en el mercado de vivienda
bueno donde dormir Raúl Esa fue la
pregunta que seguramente se hicieron en
su momento todos los que están hoy en
doha la respuesta la encontraron al
final entre cruceros campamentos en el
desierto habitaciones adaptadas en
contenedores y hasta sitios cercanos
como Dubai la lucha por la vivienda sin
embargo no se limitó a los turistas el
Frenesí inmobiliario de Qatar ha hecho
que los alquileres se disparen y que los
residentes se queden sin sus propias
casas a pesar de que según el gobierno
se dispusieron alrededor de 130.000
habitaciones les están cobrando más por
el arriendo que tenemos de cifra según
la revista especializada marca la boleta
más económica en Qatar costó unos 69
dólares esto para partidos en fases de
grupos Pero quien quisiera ir a la final
tuvo que desembolsar mínimo 1600 dólares
Estos son más o menos 8 salarios mínimos
colombianos al mes Daniela como siempre
Gracias por toda la información
información económica nos vemos la
próxima semana con más